John what's the question you're asked
most when it comes to independent film
distribution and how has your answer
changed over the years uh well probably
a few years ago it was how could I get
someone else to release my film you know
is the common question you know it's
like why do I still have to do this work
you know and I still get that from
filmmakers you know but i think you know
if I'm going to be pollyannaish which I
tend to be mr. Pollyanna I I feel like
it's the the the the debate has shifted
from oh my god why do I have to do this
didn't there isn't there someone else
who's going to do this for me and you
know I want to get a sales agent so I
can sell my film and move on it's moved
a bit from that to where filmmakers will
start to entertain the idea that they
have to be kind of engaged on a regular
basis kind of like musicians in a sense
that you know there's still some
resistance or some questioning of how I
do that as a filmmaker but i think the
desire and the awareness we're kind of
there now with that question of how do
you engage audiences on a consistent
basis where we were three years ago with
why do i have to release my film myself
so I think in three years you know which
has been the transition period I'm
hoping that filmmakers that in three
years the notion of engaging your
audience on a consistent basis will be a
non-issue you know just like now it's
less of an issue now with people
understanding that they have to kind of
take on this responsibility themselves
that not even the responsibility that
even understanding that what I've been
saying for a while is that Phil makings
a two step process or is this whole
process which includes making your fill
and engaging an audience that that's all
part of one hole and you can't have you
can't do one without understanding that
you have to do the other
you